what was the fight all about I saw it
I'm like what are they fighting them
because obviously you guys are not
you're speaking in uh important
Portuguese what had happened it was
right at the height of this reporting I
was doing in Brazil that was extremely
tumultuous it was really kind of shaking
the country to its its foundations so it
was very polarizing and the person with
whom I had had this fight had gone on
his own show I think maybe
like six weeks earlier and it said
something like you know my husband
um who recently passed away but at the
time he was a member of Congress and I
was in the middle of this uh this that
doing this journalism and he said
something like what I want to know is
they have they adopted two kids they're
raising two kids who's taking care of
these kids he's a congressman he's doing
all this [__] in Brasilia the other
ones dealing with stolen documents who's
raising the kids as though it's uncommon
these days for kids to have two parents
who are working I think we need a judge
a minor judge to go and investigate
whether these kids should be taken out
of the home so if there's anything that
you know as a father someone can say
that is going to make you kind of angry
it's maybe you should have your kids
taken away from you and then when I got
to this interview he wasn't supposed to
be there they told me at the last minute
he would be
I said fine I'm happy to talk to anybody
they sat him down I don't know if you
saw the video go to 417. trust me I saw
it inches look at how close we were oh
my God it's like we were like sitting on
top of each other Glenn you're ready to
throw down at this point yeah
you know you're sizing up his Jaws I
mean I was you know they wanted they
they started off by like hey let's talk
about the news and I said yeah before we
do that I'm gonna need an apology there
we go Glenn Greenwald getting it in
right there you'll see I did not
initiate the physical confrontation but
you did finish it though oh [__] glad
Glenn oh Glenn oh Glenn you gotta block
your face dude no no no that's about to
come wait wait for it five seconds hold
on five seconds
[Music]
so yeah that's the kind of thing I'm
ready for it did you [__] slap him yeah
I mean it was hard you see this thing
gigantic guy there was like the Jerry
Springer security team holding me back
so there was only so much I could do I
had never been in a physical
confrontation on a news program before
it's not like I go around engaging in
fistically is this a Big Show no yeah
it's a gigantic it's like one of the
biggest shows in Brazil so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]